[Musique]
c'est une question qu'on pose très
souvent pourquoi est-ce que tu
t'appelles monsieur gros pourquoi est-ce
que tu as choisi le nom de monsieur
creux et en règle générale la
proposition qu'on fait ne correspondent
pas du tout à la réalité et on pose
cette question vraiment très souvent je
me suis donc dit eh bien je vais faire
une réponse globale je vais vous dire
pourquoi je m'appelle monsieur qu'est ce
que ça veut dire d'où est ce que ça
vient d'ailleurs tout de suite avant de
vous en dire plus vous invite à mettre
la pause et a marqué en bas en
commentaire à votre avis pourquoi est-ce
que je m'appelle monsieur heureux quelle
explication vous y voyez vous mettez la
pause vous prenez le temps de le marquer
et j'irai voir les réponses et je pense
aux gens des choses assez sympathique à
les y mettez la pause allez moi j'ai le
temps aller mais la petite porte mais le
commentaire on n'est pas trop pressé
c'est bon vous l'avez fait vous êtes
revenu ok je vais aller voir ça à mon
avis avait plutôt sympa
c'est greu avec 3 erp à deux pas quatre
airs mais bel et bien trois aires si
vous cherchez à 128 heures de recherches
goreux avec trois r vous allez trouver
pas mal de résultats grrrr avec trois
aires vous allez d'abord trouver greu
sur wikipédia vous avez d'abord nos dom
a topé qui viennent du grognement d'un
chien ou d'un autre animal
vous avez également notre nomma taupe
est utilisé pour exprimer la frustration
ou la colère non la colère c'est pas ça
je suis pas quelqu'un de colérique donc
c'est pas le gros de la colle gros c'est
aussi un court métrage d'andré rigal
avec bourvil de 1952
alors même si j'adore bonville grand
dans mon cas en tout cas n'a strictement
rien à voir avec ça et même si 1952
c'est la naissance de nos mères
d'ailleurs bisous moment pour naos il y
plein de fois gros ça me fait penser à
eux
le film d'alain chabat avec 3 réseaux
skull et 4 et un minuscule ça va être
plus grands films qu'il a sorti en 2004
ça n'a strictement rien à voir j'adore
alain chabat son humour son oeuvre
mais pour que ça n'a strictement rien à
voir gros c'est aussi une triple
compilation des rolling stones sortie en
2012 à l'occasion des 50 ans du groupe
même si j'adore les rolling stones même
si je suis un très grand fan de la
musique rock bon coup ça n'a rien à voir
non le choix qui a été fait d'appeler ma
chaîne grand monsieur gros est une
histoire qui est bien plus personnel
lorsque j'ai commencé à faire mon blog
qui s'appelait monsieur greu point fr au
début parce que avant d'être une chaîne
youtube
c'est un blog et quand le projet de
faire un blog est venu il fallait un nom
à ce blog il fallait donc trouver une
idée qui me correspondait et qu'ils
allaient me coller à la peau
je l'espérais en tout cas pendant de
nombreuses années donc j'ai passé
beaucoup de temps à chercher à me
creuser la tête et je sais pas si vous
vous avez dû chercher soit un monde
marque soit mon blog soit noms de sites
sont à notre chaîne youtube alors pour
certaines personnes peut-être ça a été
une évidence et liées justement un
surnom qu'on pouvait en donner
mais je puis vous assurer que pour moi
je m'appelle aurélien c'était un peu
compliqué de trouver un nom alors j'ai
cherché cherché cherché et en fait il ya
un cas qui s'est vraiment imposé et
notamment par rapport à mon fils parce
que oui quand elliott a commencé à
parler il n'a pas fait comme tous les
enfants font en règle générale sont des
arts d'ailleurs la pédiatre nous disait
est ce que votre fils y fait ses roses
oui oui tu fais bien c'est heureux sauf
que y'at-il a jamais fait des heureux
elliott eelv et des grands c'est
toujours moi je me moquais lui et
j'allais vous dis bah alors messieurs
ont fait c'est gros et je dis ben vas-y
fais tes greu fêter greu fait grain et à
chaque fois il faisait guère et on n'a
jamais de hasard qui a voulu faire
cliquer de tapas
[Musique]
greer creux pendant ma réflexion pour
trouver le monde mon blog est bien le
nom de monsieur greu à un moment s'est
imposé comme une évidence par rapport à
mon fils d'une parce que c'était une
référence extrêmement personnelle est
que bien évidemment personne pour
réduire sans se cacher derrière tout ça
et ça permettait aussi de justifier une
deuxième raison qui paraît un peu plus
logique à savoir que monsieur greu c'est
mon surnom mais que mon nom de famille
c'est granet gr aneti aurélien gros tous
et éclairé d'un coup lorsque j'ai
cherché mon nom mon fils qui fait grève
moi je m'appelle granet monsieur greu
pour moi la part la plus importante est
la part la plus émotionnelle reste lié à
mon fils est bon et le mauvais moi aussi
vallières je vous présente elliott
toute ressemblance mais tel ne serait
que purement fortuite
tu sais qui c'est monsieur grenet et oui
c'est qu'ils mesurent eux c'est un
personnage qui fabrique des vidéos et
des banquiers adore le monde entier
alors oui c'est vrai ils meurent entier
là j'ai de la chance
c'est pourquoi est-ce que j'ai pris le
nom de monsieur re beaucoup pourquoi je
m'appelle monsieur groupe a déjà dit tu
savais pas non c'est les enfants quand
ils naissent fin d'audience papotent
inès les enfants quand ils font leurs
premières sont leurs premières paroles
souvent ils font un revers d'avoir tu te
rappelles ce que tu faisais comme son
toit en fait tracer sa télé gras et
c'est pour ça que j'ai appelé monsieur
heureux parce que je te regardait il
disait alors monsieur re confessé greu
ont fait ces gros monsieur creux et toi
tu faisais quoi qu'ils aient cru qu'ils
aient paru voilà c'est pour ça c'est
pourtant un an vi
[Musique]
voilà je vous ai confirmé secret vous
avez maintenant pourquoi j'ai décidé
d'endosser le nom monsieur groupe
pourquoi j'ai appelé mon blog
au début monsieur groupe pourquoi est-ce
que par conséquence j'ai appelé ma
chaîne monsieur gros pourquoi est ce que
mon nom de blogueur et monsieur grrrr
est ce que ça vous surprend
est ce que vous auriez peut vous en
doutez est ce que vous voyez le lien
maintenant que le marc hé bien
évidemment rang commentaires et sur ceux
envoyés beaucoup d'un bourreau
commentaires non je n'en vois pas qu'est
on se retrouve dès demain sais pas si on
va parler de teck parce que croyez moi
il ya beaucoup de choses à dire vous
envoie des bisous à deux matchs
enfin tu
il est violent
opéra / you keep on running back de
saeed et
ça
et que sont la louve en espoirs